I have a dick clarkk story so I did the
American Music Awards and Dick Clark
said to me um we're running late do not
this is so dumb too he said don't don't
say anything don't ad Li just read off
the teleprompter as big as that you know
the so I said I got it I got it Mr Clark
thank you and everyone's there Madonna
it was just everyone that you possibly
could imagine in the audiences so I come
they said please welcome to announce the
best you know best pop album of whatever
it wasn't some [__] award
katop so I walked out and I remember
there was like there wasn't even a
smattering reply it was just there was
just nothing and I thinking okay it's
weird and when I walked out they were
they had they were seating everybody
they were moving everyone was moving
everywhere so just as a comic I had to
make a reference to the fact that
there's 100 people moving around the
room so I said oh thanks everybody I
said well the problem seating everyone
the problem is there's only one Usher
and I point to Usher right that's kills
I go there's a problem there's only one
Usher she's sitting at M Don like that's
so F everyone's laugh and I do my thing
I present the thing and he please walk
and I walk off and Dick Clark's like I
just [__] told you not to do anything
and I said it was funny he says no I
said just read the teleprompter why did
you do a joke I said it killed and he
just I never forget he's so mad at me I
was like I'm it was just it was that
quick I just said well yeah so Dick
Clark he Dick Clark loved me though he
was very very apparently
heo checking on you no Dick Clark was
very very good to me he always put me on
those shows and
[Music]
yeah